the majority of relationships have to be
somewhat closer to 50 50 maybe 60 40 70
30 whatever it is but it seems like it's
less and less common that um people are
relying on one income it's usually two
if a if a woman is going 50 50 on the
bills is the woman doing more work in
the relationship
no
why because those are the women that
want to hire a chef and all that
nonsense
I mean those are they they're at work
they're playing both roles so no they're
not they usually don't do anything
seriously I disagree my last my previous
relationship I contributed financially
you know 50 50 and then at home I was
doing cleaning cooking taking care of
the house in addition so I think that's
you have to agree that that's putting in
more work if you're putting in the same
it's just automated today come on we got
a dishwasher laundry machine it's like
it's automated we got an air fryer
in like 20 minutes
I'm not asking you to Betty Crocker out
here maybe the Southern Roots the keys
there no okay you weren't doing nothing
okay yeah he's cooking for two people
but if you're contributing is it not
considered you know doing that doing
more work what is he doing
what would work work
um taking I mean we're both contributing
okay
she's about to say something yeah I want
to hear what she's about to say go ahead
no no I wasn't gonna say anything in
addition yeah
what about like what does doesn't he
like fix stuff and like fix the car oil
change that's true yeah yeah you can't
do a oil change I wasn't checking like
this
I think I think a lot of women use
marriage and relationships as like a
financial safety net so that they'll get
in a relationship so they don't have to
pay any bills
um but at the end of the day you're
supposed to be an adult right so you're
supposed to be able to um take care of
yourself
um so we push back on this whole 50 50
thing but without a man you'd have been
paying a hundred percent of the bills
and cooking with the airfryer and clean
and all those things and it's like why
do we you know have 50 50 of such a big
deal like if we paying um half of the
bills then we can't respect the math you
know
I was going to say that I think a lot a
lot of attitude comes with that with
that 50 50. I think women feel entitled
to be able to control the household
my in my honest opinion I would like the
woman had an option so even if she
desires to work I think her having an
option is a different mindset but if a
man doesn't provide
eventually you're gonna see that tussle
when it comes to arguments when the
coins when it comes to back and forth
like she's going to feel like she has
one up because you can't 100 provide for
the household
I agree with that yeah
why
it's like okay so I think Austin was
trying to say or I'm sorry for getting
married Jessica was trying to say like
you know you go out you work and then
you come in and take care of the house
we're assuming it's back in the days
right like no Roomba and air fryer
movement
and it's like I can understand how I'm
draining it can be so you're going out
working as equal as your man and then
coming in and having to cook take care
of the kids and sexually please him
because you know yeah
like I understand where it can get
stressful so having the um option to
work as opposed to having to go out to
work because if I don't get up then the
light bill won't pay while my man is
like doing a lot but it's but it's
interesting because it's not like you
know it's like a lot of times I think we
want traditional outcomes but we're not
traditional women anymore how many of us
are 22 in virgins
you know
what I mean like even when they used to
cook like they would make [ __ ] from
scratch you know like who who knows how
to make like a bunch of [ __ ] from
scratch nowadays it was a whole like
that's why Kevin Samuels would always
say like do you have a cookbook do they
have that in Brazil
and they make stuff from scratch yeah
just about everything
they don't have air fryers
so in 2022 since we're not traditional
women anymore what do you think women
should bring to the table and what
should men bring to the table
women need to be peaceful in the United
States
are you saying we're not
you live in England right yeah I haven't
been here in the United States y'all are
not peaceful uh y'all want 50 50. I
don't want to do 50 50. I don't know how
to cook
you shouldn't be stressing me out I had
a chick I was paying 100 well let me say
x I was paying 100 of the bills for and
I I don't even want to talk too much
about it but it was annoying as hell
living with her and uh yeah y'all are
not peaceful so she wasn't like
contributing at all no she didn't do a
damn thing actually
I could not not even wash the seat so
yeah real lazy as hell but
um
how long did she live with you six
months and then I got rid of her why'd
you keep her that long
that's a good question I knew after
three months it was time well yeah my
mom knew after three months because she
you know Mom said they had some sort of
energy or some [ __ ] like that she's like
oh the Lord is telling me you need to
get rid of it
seriously
did you talk about like uh household
stuff before you gotten had her move in
well she should have been doing this in
her in her mom's house and you should be
washing your own shoes I shouldn't have
to tell you that you're not doing
nothing I shouldn't right
you should be more than happy till
you're living rent free electric bill
free grocery free
I won't even wash the damn dishes no do
you think it's because she didn't know
like her role did you ask her to no
everybody knows how to wash dishes I
meant like know her role you're paying
the bills what is she I reminded her she
didn't get the memo so that was it was
she really attractive is that why she
kind of got away with this one is the
worst yeah yeah so what would you rate
her one to ten
um nine like a nine so you kind of let
her get away with it that's probably
what did it yeah yeah
do you think what if she was like a a
six or a five you think you think she's
still
the ones that you're barely sexually
attracted to do the most and uh yeah
yeah they for sure they're on a
tightrope they can't get away with
nothing no I mean like do you think you
still you'd let them get away with it
one night it's like you get more
leverage based on it not anymore though
nobody
no no
you learned your lesson yeah
has that ever happened because you you
two are married
um so how familiar I don't know how long
you got you've been married for a while
oh you said you're in a relationship how
long have you been in a relationship
um it's fairly no fairly okay so you're
still familiar with the dating scene
yeah have you had any crazy stories like
that where like I don't know some girls
are doing nothing for like what's what's
your modern dating story do you have any
uh
yeah
so I was dating this uh like realtor and
she didn't have any kids so
um and she was up there in age and and
the question that a lot of men always
asked is why is she single why is she
having the kids and so um but once you
start dating them you just start to see
different reasons as to why they are
saying when they're not married so I
just think it was more of like a reality
check like she was always about her
money it was to the point where she was
trying to sell me [ __ ] you know and it's
just like she didn't know how to turn
the sale off so she trying to she was
trying to like eat a condo no just uh
like it'd be like the smallest things
like hey like I bought this uh this hat
I can't fit it
um you know would you want to buy it
from and I'm just like why would I buy
like we're dating like why the hell
would I buy this [ __ ] from it it was
just the most craziest thing so uh I
start to see how and she was also
accounting my money as well you know she
wanted to see what I was bringing to her
table so to speak so she was looking at
me to see what value I was to her so I
think the mindset is just different
what about what about you
so what's the question that I'm
answering you've been married 15 years
so how did you how are you familiar with
the dating scene like how do you even
know what's what's going on I talk to a
lot of crazy people so
conversations I get a chance to see
what's still going on I think the
biggest thing is that no no offense to
of course I love all the ladies but
women have to grow up yeah we've afford
the women to be be luxurious babies
that's it no good go to work be
independent make your own money but
being responsible a lot of women are
just not responsible and the cutest she
is the more she gets away with and I
think if we're gonna if women are going
to bring something to the table with
peace be responsible be able to say I'm
sorry when you're wrong about something
and don't deflect and make it seem like
the man is doing something wrong right
if something goes wrong don't be the
first to point the finger sometimes look
at yourself I think it's maturity that a
lot of men particularly successful mean
in this age you know cute ain't enough
anymore you gotta have some peace you've
got to have some maturity those are
things that I'm looking for can I play
Devil's Advocate okay okay go ahead
because the menu bad too
that's gonna be my next question so yeah
go ahead go ahead I mean it's it sucks
for um women to especially if you like
more traditional minded and you want
that provider and protector guy a lot of
these men are sims no fans if I can say
that word
a lot of these men are like um loyalty
to their mama you know like
um they praise the woman and stuff and
it's like man up like you know do
something like yes there's like a Sim
pandemic yeah it's like a lot of
feminists
[Laughter]
and I mean I know we talk a lot about
the Modern Woman and we just like just
push the Modern Men to the side because
you know it's like do you think women I
feel like women created the Modern Men
though because we told them we wanted
them to open up to us we want to be
treated like Queens we hate the guys
that treat us like Queens it's kind of
like what comes first the chicken or the
egg because then the man allow us to be
too dominant or are we too dominant I
think it's because I think it's birth
control
I think birth control started everything
yes yeah Pearl's World I'd ban birth
control
yeah because if you look at the number
of women on birth control and the
divorce rate like the the chart is
really similar like it's like the more
women got on birth control so it's like
what started it the hose
that's my my opinion me would lie too
this is just this is fascinating me and
we'll lie too yeah we were told that
women want a sweet guy someone who can't
listen
someone who's empathetic what will I do
and so what now we're giving women this
and women don't want this because we're
starting to see that there's a
differences between men and women yeah
and now women who raise this generation
of men they don't want the men that they
raise anymore I think we thought we
wanted it it's like because women we
don't know what we want
and you know baby song I'll cook for you
as soon as I get home from work I'll
wash your clothes and a lot of men in
the 90s like fell for that so yeah I
agree okay so it's the women's fault I
just wanted to Circle back in my head
what do you guys think wait you've been
quiet all right you've been quiet what
do you think
um do you think what is your experience
been with Modern Men
um
well I have a really good boyfriend so
he's
um but I think I've dated men in the
past that are Mama's boys and they're
raised a certain way and so they expect
you to be a certain way and usually I
think a lot of women now are really
independent and don't want to take care
of like
the man like you're their mom so yeah I
guess in my past relationships I have
been the provider done all the things
that I thought that I was supposed to do
and now I'm just like ready to sit back
and not not do that anyone have the man
um provide and be the leader and take
care of the
relationship as well do you think you
could do that even if you're splitting
at 50 50.
I think allowing myself to take off the
reins a little bit and give the man like
more responsibility I think
um I would be able to but splitting 50
50
[Music]
um
I don't know sorry I could just like
kind of turned at that there but um yeah
I don't know having the man contribute
financially and then the home 50 50.
it's it's interesting
so it sounds like now
like so so no like it see it seems like
you'd only be able to submit in a way if
it wasn't 50 50.
yeah I think it's difficult if you've
never been in that situation to allow um
completely to take off and just let the
man provide 100 I've never had that so
I'm not sure
well my next visit I would love that I
guess but so is it that you can't do it
now currently
I just haven't been in a position
too yeah I've always provided yeah okay
and I think I come from a very strong
relationship with my mother who was the
Sole Provider and so I I've always seen
that so I'm just expected in my own mind
okay maybe I'm supposed to be the
provider and like
yeah well I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you firsthand you might want to
test it because uh I think that your
mother raised you and I've been in a
situation where the mother had a heavy
influence on the woman yeah and it
didn't play well because it just read
the relationship the wrong way because
I'm pretty sure there's some other areas
within the relationship that may have
some struggles because of that right
yeah absolutely as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible